katastrophengebiete gibt es praktisch
überall auf unserem planeten
über eine verwüstung trümmer zerstörter
gebäude aufgerissen autobahn
es ist verstörend als wäre da eine
übersinnliche macht am werk gewesen
alles andere als normal
manche unglück gekommen wie aus dem
nichts andere hat der mensch selbst
dabei geführt
man wirklich angst es ist beispiellos
gibt es sonst nirgends auf der erde
es sieht aus wie eine post
apokalyptische landschaft wurde sie
bombardier hat jemand überlebt was ist
passiert
zerstört durch kräfte der natur fatale
menschliche fehleinschätzungen oder
bizarre phänomene hier sind fünf der
erstaunlichsten katastrophengebiete der
welt
eine ganze stadt jetzt ist sie weg
zerfallende bomben ruinen aus
vergangener zeit einst rosam erschaffen
heute nur noch schatten ihrer selbst
zeit ihre geheimnisse zu lüften
[Musik]
das ist erschreckend die auswirkungen
dieser zerstörerischen kräfte könnten
katastrophal sei
[Musik]
eines der erstaunlichsten
katastrophengebiete der welt
an japans ostküste finden wir eine
seltsame ansammlung verlassener gebäude
früher war es eine geschäftige gegend
voll mit verschiedenen gebäuden
wohnhäusern und fabrik
frage war hier eine überwältigende kraft
abwehren es sieht aus als hätte hier ein
monster getötet
nur wenige kilometer entfernt ein ganz
anderes bild
irgendwas stimmt da nicht es fühlt sich
an wie eine geisterstadt oder einen
zombiefilm
alles ist abgeregelt überall
sicherheitszäune da kommst du nicht rein
es ist eine no go
[Musik]
wo es hakt in einen teil des gebiets
herrschen verwüstung und zerstörung im
anderen teil ist alles völlig intakt
aber keine menschenseele ist die
große frage ist wie passt das alles
zusammen
die high school in der stadt tome yoga
ist leer und verwaist
wenig scheint sich verändert zu haben
seit zuletzt schüler hier waren
es ist das hauptgebäude es gab drei
klassen pro jahrgang insgesamt neun
dann fleißig trainiert
[Musik]
war hier die rektorin
einige jahre vor der katastrophe hat sie
die schule verlassen sie erinnert sich
an ihre schüler
badminton fußball auf diese sportarten
konzentrierte sich die schule sie wollte
international erfolgreiche athleten
hervorbringen daran orientierte sich das
programm
[Musik]
[Applaus]
2011 endet das ehrgeizige projekt ab
[Musik]
seitdem stehen die gebäude leer
an den moment der katastrophe erinnert
eine uhr an der wand
sehen sie sich die uhr am schulgebäude
an sie ist um zwei uhr 46 stehen
geblieben sie hat sich seit dem 11 märz
2011 nicht mehr bewegt
[Applaus]
um 14 uhr 46 erschüttert an diesem tag
ein erdbeben der stärke 9 die ostküste
japans
das sehen sie sich die uhr am
schulgebäude sie ist um zwei uhr 46
steril sie hat sich seit dem 11 märz
2011 nichts mehr bewegt
das erdbeben war so stark es verschob
angeblich ganz st zwei meter nach osten
wegen des erdbebens wird die stadt
evakuiert aber es gibt einen weiteren
grund warum niemand zurückkehren darf
nicht weltweit
weniger gebäude ein als es in anderen
teilen der welt
das erdbeben war nur der anfang die
gegend wurde von gleich zwei weiteren
tödlichen ereignissen heimgesucht das
epizentrum des erdbebens liegt 130
kilometer östlich im pazifischen ozean
es löst eine zweite verheerende
katastrophe aus
wenn das epizentrum eines erdbebens
unter dem meer liegt verschiebt sich der
boden und damit auch das wasser darüber
und wo geht es hin
das flache küstengebiet liegt genau in
der schusslinie
ein tsunami rollt mit
spitzengeschwindigkeiten um die 800
kilometer pro stunde auf die küste zu
15 minuten nach dem erdbeben kommt er an
die tsunami welle war so hoch dass sie
die küstenschutzanlagen überspülte und
das gebiet dahinter flut
man stellt sich immer einen riesigen
turm hohen brecher vor aber tatsächlich
ist es keine einzelne welle sondern eher
eine riesige flut die landeinwärts
drückt und alles unter wasser
wenn man sieht wie die wassermassen
häuser zerstören und menschen mitreißen
ist es ganz egal ob man 100 kilometer
weit weg lebt oder auf der anderen seite
des globus
kann sich gut vorstellen wie schrecklich
das sein muss
der tsunami fließt zehn kilometer
landeinwärts
ein gebiet von 300 quadratkilometern ist
betroffen
der tsunami war verheerend er zerstörte
die küstenstädte und große teile der
infrastruktur rund 19.000 menschen
wurden getötet
bauingenieure ich weiß wie häuser gebaut
werden müssen damit sie stabil sind und
die naturgewalten stand
die natur
ungeheuerliche kräfte entfalten
inzwischen wurden neue küsten
befestigungen gebaut und gebiete zurück
gewonnen
andere aber bleiben gesperrt
die gebiete wurden verwüstet und
zerstört andere sind verlassen sehen
aber ganz intakt und normal aus nur dass
keine menschen da sind
vielleicht ein paar sicherheitsbeamte
die tatsache dass hier immer wachen
patroullieren zeigt dass es hier immer
noch eine bedrohung
warum sind diese gebiete nach all den
jahren immer noch tabu
die tsunami flut die durch das schwere
erdbeben ausgelöst wurde trifft direkt
auf das kernkraftwerk in fukushima
[Musik]
die regierung wurde von einem dreifachen
die atomkatastrophe
es kommt zur kernschmelze in den
reaktorblöcken 1 2 und 3 gibt es heftige
explosionen
gefährlicher mengen strahlung entweichen
in die atmosphäre
die reaktoren geschmolzen wurde sehr
viel radioaktivität frei mit enormen
auswirkungen auf die ganze
die regierung rief den notstand aus sie
befreite evakuieren das gebiet
zunächst gilt der befehl nur für einen
radius von zwei kilometern um das
atomkraftwerk
doch dann müssen auch die stadt tome
yoga und das gymnasium geräumt werden
die leute damals war das erdbeben der
tsunami hatte hier ist ja keine großen
folgen
am nächsten morgen
wollten alle nach hause gehen und
aufräumen aber
dann mussten sie die stadt verlassen
niemand hatte zeit zu packen
die leute mussten in ihrer auto steigen
und sofort los
bis zum ende des zweiten tages wird die
evakuierungszone auf einen radius von 20
kilometern ausgedehnt aus angst vor
strahlung werden bis zu 50 kilometer
entfernte gebiete zusätzlich geräumt
insgesamt sind fast 200.000 menschen
gezwungen ihre häuser zu verlassen
am 12 märz verließen die bewohner von
tomica die stadt
erst sechs jahre später am 31 märz 2017
durften sie in ihre häuser zurückkehren
nördlich vom tomioka durchschneidet die
nationalstraße sechs die sperrzone
die nationalstraße 6 zu befahren ist
eine krasse erfahrung
man darf sie täglich nur begrenzt nutzen
und man darf in der sperrzone nirgendwo
anhalten
die strahlung ist einfach zu hoch man
muss die fenster zu lassen und zügig
durch war
da drüben sind häuser aber natürlich
wunder niemand
einige geschäfte hier in der nähe sind
völlig unberührt gedenkt
sehen immer noch so aus wie vor acht
oder neun jahren
nie zuvor hat eine säuberungsaktion nach
einem atomunfall so viel geld
verschlungen nach und nach werden immer
mehr gebiete wieder freigegeben darunter
auch tomioka die folgen der katastrophe
sind immer noch offensichtlich der
kontaminiert mutterboden musste
weggebaggert werden um die strahlung zu
stoppen in der ganzen gegend sind hügel
davon aufgeschüttet die strahlung soll
so eingedämmt werden
jeder katastrophe geht das leben
irgendwo weiter der aufwand das
gigantisch was wird gemacht und nach und
nach sind die entsprechenden gebiete
wieder sicher genommen um sie zu öffnen
die vielen lastwagen transportieren das
kontaminierte material
gibt es fast nur arbeitsfahrzeug
wenn die strahlung abnimmt werden die
evakuierungsbefehlen nach und nach
aufgehoben
aber im moment ist diese gegend noch
gesperrt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der tsunami hat tausende von menschen
getötet und die atomkatastrophe ist
immer noch gegenstand großer
kontroversen
das schlimmste an dem reaktorunfall war
nicht die strahlen sondern der eingriff
in das leben der menschen
nicht nur die atmosphäre wurde
sondern auch die seele der leute
es ist paradox das ganze ist als
verheerender atomunfall
tatsächlich war laut angaben der
weltgesundheitsorganisation
die menge der ausgetretenen strahlung
nicht
typischerweise an gab aber eine
folgestudie das mehr als 1600 menschen
an den folgen der evakuierung gestört
die meisten der opfer waren alt oder
litten an vorerkrankungen
toxikologie unterstützt betroffene heute
in einem beratungszentrum
[Musik]
als der evakuierungsbefehl teilweise
aufgehoben wurde bin ich wieder hierher
gezogen
ich wohne jetzt in tomioka mache diese
arbeit
die katastrophe hat unser aller leben
für immer verändert
[Musik]
in columbia county pennsylvania scheint
eine ganze stadt einfach verschwunden zu
sein
wie eine geisterstadt nur ohne stadt
rechtwinklig angelegte straßen und
deuten auf eine typisch amerikanische
kleinstadt der autor david de cock
erinnert sich noch gut an diese zeit
dieses foto stammt aus dem oktober 1983
wie man sieht war das damals noch eine
intakte statt das ist alles weg
eine landstraße ohne autos fundamente
ohne hoyzer eine
polizeiwache ohne polizisten
was ihr passiert ist würde man
eigentlich für unmöglich halten
bis in die 1970 er jahre ist sein
trailer eine ganz normale stadt aber
dann häufen sich seltsame ereignisse
[Musik]
giftige gase dampfende risse in der erde
ein loch das sich auftut und beinahe
einen teenager verschluckt
kann dampf aus diesem riesigen riss im
highway alle fragten sich warum weil wir
glaubten es sei ein vulkan
in wirklichkeit steht der boden unter
ihren füßen in flammen auch jetzt noch
das ist ein bohrloch wenn ich den deckel
ab schraube sehen wir was das feuer da
und macht
schön heiß ich kann den typischen
schwefelgeruch des feuers riechen
central liegt direkt auf einem weit
verzweigten netz verlassener kohleminen
es wird vermutet dass ein depot niemand
seinen weg in das unterirdische
labyrinth gefunden hat und sich unter
den häusern ausbreitet
verschiedene bürgerinitiativen forderten
eine evakuierung aber es dauerte noch
zwei jahre bis etwas passiert
1984 werden alle einwohner sind
rallye-ass umgesiedelt und ihre häuser
abgerissen
[Musik]
heute wirkt es fast so als hätte es die
stadt nie gegeben
aber eine frage bleibt
wie lange wird es weiter brennen
schätzungen besagen 200 bis 250 jahre
aber in wirklichkeit weiß das keiner das
feuer wird rennen das ihm entweder die
kohle oder der sauerstoff ausgeht
[Musik]
auf der indonesischen insel java hat
eine verblüffende katastrophe eine ganze
gemeinde auf einige wenige gebäude
reduziert
es gibt häuser es gibt fabriken es gibt
tempel
es gibt straßen aber sie hören an diesem
rätselhaften wahl oder da ich einfach
auf
da sind warnschilder aber es ist unklar
was dahinter ist offensichtlich muss
hier was schlimmes geschehen sein mit
einschneidenden folgen
auch jenseits des walds stellen sich
viele fragen
und oben sieht man etwas
riesigen see ausschlag manche stellen
sind nass an anderen blue bird ich
wieder andere teile liegen trocken und
rissig in der sonne
die ausdehnung dieses sees ist gewaltig
so weit das auge reicht
und dann stellt sich die frage
entwickelt sich das noch ist das der
endpunkt oder geht das noch weiter
in seiner betrachtung erkennt man
einzelne bauwerke und anlagen im schlamm
einmal etwas gewesen sein aber der
schlamm hat alles zugedeckt
wie ist das passiert war es eine
naturkatastrophe oder haben menschen es
verursacht
[Applaus]
womöglich beides
[Musik]
aber bei all dem schlamm haben die
experten höhe es herauszufinden
bis 2006 war der bezirk pudong noch eine
blühende ländliche gegend
havanna lebte damals hier
[Musik]
mein dorf
es ging uns gut aber dann kam der
schlamm
früher hat unsere familie zusammengelebt
aber jetzt ist die ganze verwandtschaft
überall verstreut
das ist der schlammvulkan ceo auch
bekannt als los
[Musik]
das war eine belebte gegend mit qi
landwirtschaft mit rund 60.000 menschen
feldern genug arbeit und fruchtbaren
boden
am 29 mai 2006 beginnt die
überschwemmung ohne jede vorwarnung
der schlamm verschluckt inzwischen 110
quadratkilometer großes areal und er
will immer noch mehr
die menschen rannten um ihr leben sie
riefen
schlammlawine
und es wurde einfach immer mehr
[Musik]
die schlammlawine begrub 16 dörfer 24
fabriken hunderte von reisfeldern und
fischteichen
[Musik]
hier waren die wohnhäuser der friedhof
der schule gar die moschee
jetzt liegt alles unter dem schlamm
begraben
havanna und tausende weitere einwohner
von tom müssen ihre heimatdörfer
verlassen
die auswirkungen waren immens
60.000 menschen wurden vertrieben ihre
häuser einfach weg die gegend
unbewohnbar
eine gaspipeline explodiert und tötete
13 menschen
das ackerland wurde zum
katastrophengebiet
ich erinnere mich noch an den tag an dem
ich mit meinen kindern wecken
jetzt weiß ich nicht mehr weiter
was soll aus ihnen werden
bekommen sie genug zu essen
werde je wieder eine anständige arbeit
bekommen
ich kämpfe nur noch für die kinder
[Musik]
was hat eine schlamm explosion im boden
verursacht
180 tausend kubikmeter schlamm rota
[Applaus]
zunächst bleibt die ursache ein rätsel
ökonomischer hinsicht war das ganze ein
desaster die schäden beliefen sich auf
geschätzte drei milliarden
versuche den schlamm sie einzeln
entscheiden
havanna bleibt in ihrem dorf bis sie und
alle anderen bewohner gezwungen werden
ihr zuhause zu verlassen
wenn der schlamm halbtrocken ist sieht
man die risse
ganz trocken ist eher weich wie
wüstensand
der salzgehalt ist sehr hoch oh
ja sehr salzig
früher wuchsen hier bäume
jetzt ist das eine wüste hier wächst
nichts mehr
[Musik]
der schlamm ist nicht wie bei ihnen
er ist voller schwermetall gase wie
kohlendioxid und methan steigen auf was
auch nicht gesund ist das ganze ist eine
gewaltige umwelt
von oben gibt es kaum anhaltspunkte
woher der giftige schlamm eigentlich
kommt und wieso das alles so urplötzlich
angefangen hat
muss eindeutig etwas außergewöhnliches
passiert sein die leute bauen keine
häuser an orten wo der boden regelmäßig
schlussspurt
der tödliche schlamm ist kochend heiß
ein deutlicher hinweis auf seinen
ursprung
indonesiens 17.000 inseln sitzen auf
einem tektonischen pulverfass
indonesien ist geologisch insgesamt sehr
aktiv mit vielen erdbeben und vulkanen
in dem gebiet leben seit jahrtausenden
menschen es kann also dort nicht ständig
vulkanausbrüche gegeben haben
unter par an drückt die erdwärme eine
mischung aus wasser und erdreich an die
oberfläche wo sie als lang vulkan
ausbricht
[Musik]
die schiere menge verblüfft die experten
sie kann nur einen ursprung haben
sie ist teil eines viel größeren
geologischen ländern
lucies gase stammen aus einem 15
kilometer entfernten aktiven
vulkansystemen
es produziert einen schier endlosen
vorrat an schlamm der durch ein netz von
tunneln gepresst wird aber das erklärt
noch nicht wieso der schlammvulkan so
plötzlich ausgerechnet hier ausbricht
[Musik]
die frage ist auch ob es sich um ein
reines naturphänomen handelt oder der
mensch irgendwie dazu beigetragen hat
tätige öl und gaskonzern gerät unter
verdacht
[Musik]
erdgasgewinnung ist ein heikler prozess
man bohrt ein loch durch mehrere
gesteinsschichten die bisher alles
darunter eingeschlossen jetzt drückt das
gas durch die bohrung nach oben und
nimmt alles mit was
steht unter enormem druck als ob sie
eine limo flasche öffnen und alles
scheint nach oben
einige behaupten dass 2006 unterhalb des
bezirks pour homme das undenkbare
geschah
[Musik]
ein unternehmen das nach erdgas bord hat
gibt vor so konnte das unter druck
stehende wasser und der schlamm aus der
tiefe nach oben gelangen
[Musik]
nach dieser theorie stieß die bohrung
nur 200 meter vom späteren schlammvulkan
entfernt auf eine spalte im fels die
eine verbindung mit dem aktiven
vulkansystemen hat
[Musik]
danach gab es kein halten mehr
die bohrfirma weist jedoch auf eine
weitere mögliche ursache hin
ein erdbeben dass es zwei tage vorher in
300 kilometern entfernung gegeben hatte
soll die verwerfung ausgelöst hat
die bohrfirma behauptet das erdbeben sei
stark genug gewesen um die felsspalte zu
öffnen viele wissenschaftler bestreiten
dass die menschen deren häuser von
schlamm begraben sind haben keine
zweifel
warum mussten sie in einem wohngebiet
bohren
[Musik]
hätten sie es nicht im wald machen
können oder in einem anderen gebiet hat
keine häuser stehen nur warner und ihre
nachbarn haben von der bohrfirma eine
kleine entschädigung erhalten
sie gaben uns 20 prozent der summe und
sagten sie würden den rest in bar
bezahlen das haben sie aber nicht
gemacht
heute bricht der vulkan immer noch
regelmäßig aus und überzieht das land
mit schlamm aus den tiefen der erde
landschaft hat sich total verändert
im grunde ist das aber eine menschliche
tragödie immer noch kämpfen menschen um
entschädigung
für die bewohner vom programm hat sich
das leben seit dem ausbruch völlig
verändert
[Musik]
das leben der leute völlig auf den kopf
gestellt sie mussten ihre arbeitsplätze
verlassen
die lokale wirtschaft liegt am boden nur
varna und ihre freunde haben nur noch
wenige möglichkeiten geld zu verdienen
dank des katastrophen tourismus können
sie wenigstens als fremdenführer
arbeitet sie erzählen den touristen ihre
geschichte das hätten sie sich zwar nie
ausgesucht aber es ist ihre neue
lebensgrundlage
[Musik]
in argentinien stehen in einer desolaten
gegend die ruinen einer stadt
alles ist mit einer feinen weißen
schicht bedeckt
es ist eine falle geisterhafte szenerie
nichts deutet auf die ursache der
zerstörung und doch liegt die antwort in
dieser hellen schicht die alles
überzieht
die meisten katastrophengebiete sind
menschenleer dieses jedoch nicht
ich bin partner nowak der einzige
bewohner der ruine ich bin geblieben ich
war mir sicher dass eines tages jemand
zurückkommen würde früher war der ort
berühmt die leute kamen von überall her
dies sind die ruinen von wpp
im zwanzigsten jahrhundert war das ein
luxuriöser urlaubsort ansehen
dass sie ursprünglich einen ballsaal
später wurde auch als theater genutzt
buenos aires traten hier auf
die hauptattraktion der stadt jedoch
liegt gleich nebenan der mineralreiche
salzsee bekannt für seine angeblich
heilende wirkung
sein zerstörerisches potenzial erkennt
niemand
im november 1985 beginnt es zu regnen
und hört nicht wieder auf schließlich
tritt der see über seine ufer
[Musik]
red und nach und nach verschlangen die
fluten die stadt
1993 stand das wasser zehn metern
wurde ein modernes atlantis
dann im lauf von jahrzehnten zieht sich
das wasser wieder zurück das hinterlässt
verwüstung
alles was sie heute sehen war 20 jahre
lang weg
rückt eine dicke salzschicht es ist ein
irrer anblick
für pablo nowak den letzten bewohner der
stadt ist es ein ständiger kampf
solange ich laufen und sprechen kann und
mein gedächtnis funktioniert
[Musik]
von stillen tragödien bis zu
unterirdischen gewalten rätselhafte
naturereignissen und von menschen
verursachten katastrophen
fast scheint es als fühlten sich die
menschen zum unglück hingezogen
[Musik]
unser letztes beispiel liegt mehr als
1000 kilometer nördlich des polarkreises
an der eisigen küste spitzbergens
ihr droht eine unmittelbare gefahr und
deren ursache bedroht sogar den ganzen
planeten
[Musik]
spitzbergen fühlt sich an wie das ende
der welt eine brutale landschaft kalt
karg und welt
in münchen winter ist alles verschneit
und es ist immer dunkel im sommer
dagegen hat man 24 stunden tageslicht
der extreme
die stadt ist die nördlichste siedlung
der wert mit 1000 immer mehr einwohner
weiter nördlich kann man praktisch nicht
ohne
wenn der schnee schmilzt tauchen am
berghang oberhalb der stadt bröckelnde
ruinen auf
doch sie sind nicht die einzigen
verlassenen bauwerke hier
den größten teil des ortes scheint es
gut zu gehen aber dann gibt es noch
diese verlassenen austeilen
den verlassene gebäude kurz vor dem
einsturz aber diese noch gut aus
es ist niemand da und das merkwürdige
ist es wirkt ziemlich modern offenbar
ist nichts passiert warum die mutter
einen ersten hinweis geben die ruinen
weiter oben
am stadtrand stehen alte industriell
anmutende gebäude es sind ruinen
verloren und vergessen
und da fragt man sich den modernen
gebäuden in der stadt vielleicht das
gleiche schicksal droht
eine tödliche bedrohung liegt in der
luft und könnte weitreichende folgen
haben
die probleme der stadt sind arzt und
potenziell tödlich zwei menschen sind
schon ums leben gekommen
was hier geschieht ist erschreckt es ist
erst der anfang von etwas das bald außer
kontrolle geraten könnte
folgen wären katastrophal
[Musik]
im neunzehnten jahrhundert ist
spitzbergen ein weit abgelegene und sehr
gefährlicher ort nur wenige verschlägt
es hierher
[Musik]
walfänger und robbenjäger waren lange
die einzigen die zu der inselgruppe hoch
im norden kam bis 1906 ihr ein
amerikaner namens john long er begann
nach kohle zu suchen
die jahrhundertwende veränderte sich die
welt radikal und diese veränderung wird
von kohle angetrieben
an so einem ort kohle gefunden wird
steigt der wert des bodens enorm
die stadt long libyen verdankt ihre
existenz den kohle boom
aber 100 jahre später hat die kohle ihre
bedeutung verloren
[Musik]
zu einer art
deshalb geht weltweit zurück
die schwindende nachfrage nach kohle
drückt die immobilienpreise aber an
dieser geschichte ist mehr dran als es
auf den ersten blick scheint
[Musik]
der stadt hat nichts mit dem niedergang
der kohle zu tun dafür gibt es einen
anderen grund
eine tödliche gefahr hat die leute zur
flucht gezwungen die frage ist was hat
der bergbau im lauf der jahre
angerichtet hat er den untergrund
irgendwie instabil gemacht
was ist das für eine gefahr warum wurden
die praktisch neuen häuser in der
arktischen tundra aufgegeben
diese gebäude gruppe wurde von den
behörden als unsicher eingestuft
mit den häusern selbst ist alles in
ordnung sie sind strukturell intakt das
problem ist der standort etwas hat sich
geändert und das macht es gefährlich
es ist ein schreckliches gefühl all die
leeren gebäude zu sehen und niemand kann
sie benutzen
hier wohnte
bis vor kurzem lebte nils lawrence on in
einer ähnlichen wohnung in der nähe
er hat erlebt wie immer mehr häuser für
die bewohner gesperrt wurden
es gibt sogenannte rote zonen
das betrifft viele leute
es kostet die gemeinde und die menschen
viel geld
meine beiden kinder haben den
kindergarten hier besucht jetzt ist er
geschlossen es ist eine traurige
geschichte
während der sommermonate droht den
gebäuden keine gefahr
[Musik]
im winter dafür umso mehr das hat lorenz
und vor einigen jahren am eigenen leib
erfahren
war gerade beim putzen da gab es
plötzlich einen großen knall
ich wusste sofort dass das eine lawine
war eine große und schnelle la vie
als ich ging ins zimmer meiner tochter
und konnte direkt durch die wand sehen
das haus war auseinandergebrochen
auf älteren luftaufnahmen ist hören
sonst aus noch zu sehen es war weder das
erste noch das einzige opfer auch andere
gebäude wurden in den letzten jahren
zerstört
in diversen 2015 wurde die stadt von
einer gewaltigen lawine überrascht
eine riesige platte aus eis und stein
die eine solche wucht hatte dass sie die
häuser angehoben und auf die andere
straßenseite geschoben hat
[Musik]
acht menschen werden verletzt zwei
getötet
bis dahin hatte niemand geglaubt eine
lawine könnte so groß werden dass sie
sogar die häuser trifft und menschen
tötet
keiner konnte sich das vorstellen
zwar stehen heute überall lawinen
brecher aber für manche teile des ortes
ist das risiko einfach zu groß
die häuser sind immer noch in gefahr im
winter stehen sie direkt in der
schusslinie
deshalb wurde angeordnet diese ortsteile
vollständig zu evakuieren
als die häuser die heute in der roten
zone legen gebaut wurden war dieses
gebiet noch nicht gefährdet
das hat sich mit der zeit geändert
aber aus welchem grund
die ruinen oben am hang sind ein teil
der antwort und
die konsequenzen sind verblüffend
[Musik]
ironischerweise steckt die selbe
industrie die diesen ort groß gemacht
hat hinter der bedrohung
durch die verbrennung von kohle gelangt
so viel kohlendioxid in die atmosphäre
dass der planet sich erwärmt
an der örtlichen universität hat die
gletscher forscherin heidi silvestre die
veränderung des klimas auf spitzbergen
untersucht
die schwarze kurve zeigt die globalen
temperatur veränderungen der letzten 120
jahre die orange kurve zeigt die
veränderungen in spitzbergen
in den letzten zwanzig bis dreißig
jahren gehen die kurven stark
auseinander in spitzbergen steigen sie
doppelt so schnell wie im rest der welt
seit
1971 sind die temperaturen hier im
schnitt um vier grad celsius gestiegen
das ist er sich am schnellsten erwärmte
ort der erde
[Musik]
übersteigerte variante der globalen
erwärmung mit heftigen folgen die umwelt
verändert sich dramatisch und die
einheimischen müssen ihre lebensweise
anpassen um damit klar zu kommen
viele häuser sind in lawinen bereits zum
opfer gefallen weit mehr stehen in der
schusslinie
der drastische temperaturanstieg hat
lawinen zu einer sehr realen bedrohung
gemacht
heute kennen wir den zusammenhang
zwischen dem klimawandel und der lawine
von 2015 und wir müssen leider
feststellen dass so was in zukunft immer
häufiger passieren wird
lawinen sind nicht die einzige
bedrohliche folge des klimawandels auf
spitzbergen town die gletscher in
rasantem tempo dass mehr friert im
winter nicht mehr zu der ort mag
abgelegen seien aber die alarmierenden
ereignisse sind eine warnung an uns alle
die arktischen eis tage sind wieder
kanarienvogel im kohlebergwerk was mit
dem planeten passiert passiert hier
schneller weil das wetter so extrem ist
es liegt in der menschlichen natur
wenn die katastrophe tatsächlich
passiert wenn du wartest bis schnee und
eis den berg runter auf dich zukommen
ist es zu spät
[Musik]
von den gewaltigen tektonischen kräften
bis zu unglücken die menschen verursacht
haben überall auf unserem planeten in an
uns katastrophengebiete an die
gewaltigen kräfte der natur und die
gefahr sie zu unterschätzen sie zeugen
aber auch von der fähigkeit des menschen
sich anzupassen und das unglück zu
überwinden